- Hello, everyone.
I am Brian Ray.
I head up the data and AI business line
for North America at Atos.
- Hello, everyone.
My name is Justin Cook.
I'm the global CTO for
the AWS Alliance at Atos.
- Hi, and I'm Mark Ross.
I'm our chief architect for AWS
in our engineering function.
- So we're gonna demystify
a bit about the agentic AI
and give you guys a little bit about
the critical path forward
productionizing AI
and give you a real honest landscape
of what it looks like today.
First off, a little bit
about where Atos is at.
Atos has been around 20 some years.
My group came in from a lot
of different acquisitions,
17 or so.
Philippe Salle, our chairman
of the board CEO said,
data and AI is gonna be
extremely important to consulting
and we need to make a
data and AI business line.
So that represents 2000
and we're on track to be 10,000 by 2028.
Firm overall by 80,000 folks.
So it's a small portion of a big firm,
but it's really a path forward
for us and our customers.
Myself, I'm an industry expert
and I also really rely a lot on
what the industry's saying here.
And how many here have seen the
gardener hype curves before?
I'm gonna interpret this
for you a little bit.
It's really important to understand
what they're trying to say here.
Basically, agents, believe it or not,
are at the tip of hype right now.
I know you're shocked.
Has anybody here heard AI?
Can everybody spell it?
Good.
It is a big topic and it's at
the tip of the hype right now.
Model ops is coming down
and they call this a
trough of disillusionment.
That's when people say the reality sets in
this is harder than we thought.
We have data availability issues.
We don't have the
technology needed to do it.
We need to go to the AWS
conference and learn something.
Many reasons.
It becomes the trough of disillusionment
and you see model ops.
Gen AI is already in that.
The bubbles bursted to some
degree with some of that.
And then if you see on the far side,
that's the plateau of productivity.
That's where we come
back out of that trough
and that's where we all want to get.
We want this technology to be seamless,
part of our daily business life,
and we want it to make our
lives better and easier,
not being challenged by it every day.
So that's where we want to get.
What we're hearing is we need
to make that data available.
We need it to be governed.
We need to have access to
data in all sorts of places.
SharePoint, other places like
that, protocols are coming up.
You've heard MCP
and other protocols making
that more available.
And also just being able to
take some of those use cases
and prioritize them
based off of ROI and risk
and be able to do that better.
MIT said 95% of those use cases
people plan to do are not
really getting into production.
That makes a lot of sense
if you take a lot of swings,
of course, we're all aiming to be that 5%
to get your use cases in production.
Another thing from Frances
Karamouzis and Gartner
and this is very helpful
because this lays out AI
especially GenAI in the five buckets.
On your far right, those
are your market makers.
Those are of course Anthropics
and you know Googles, Mistral,
those are the ones that are doing
the a hundred million
dollar investments in it.
On your far left, target category one.
Those are your very
consumer based easy entry.
My mom uses ChatGPT for recipes.
It doesn't make her cooking
better, but she uses it.
And your embedded technology as well,
you're getting it embedded
into your category two.
Category three is where you
start using AI to solve specific
vertical or horizontal use
cases for a specific industry
or a department.
And then the category four
is where you take your data
and you train a model or fine tune it
or you gear it specifically to a problem.
So those category three and four
it gets more expensive as
you get into those spaces.
So it's really a hockey
stick curve of cost.
Speaking of Atos,
one of our big focuses
is those category three
and category four use cases.
It requires lots of partnerships to do it,
lot of technology to do it,
but it really has a value
and we're seeing that value every day now.
The other thing that you're hearing too
is adoption problems.
People are given these tools sometimes
and there's a large fallout rate
and it depends on who you are.
There's the everyday user.
Everybody wants to move from
left to right in the slide.
Everybody does.
Everyday users want to be
able to get advanced with AI.
Your children will be better
at prompt engineering than you.
So everybody wants to use this technology.
Lots of reasons for that governance.
I always say that AI without governance
is like playing tennis without a net.
It doesn't really work and
it's not that much fun.
But everyone wants to move that direction.
If you're advanced or you're agentic
you wanna move to more advancing.
Why do people fall out of that?
Why do they fall out of that
matrix and what happens?
When they fall out of it
sometimes they'll see them shadow AI.
Shadow AI is when you're using it anyway.
Or you'll see someone
abandon it completely saying,
we're not gonna adopt this
AI technology in my workflow
because it just isn't
working well enough for me.
And then what's the solution for that?
Partners and technology help
and a need for consulting,
a need for community,
eventually there'll be a
community around agentic,
believe it or not, there'll
even be a currency someday
around agentic agents will
have their own currency
speaking to each other someday very soon.
Think about that for a second.
- Hello, everyone.
So I'd like to talk for a minute about
how we can help you get to the place
where Brian wants you to go.
At Atos we're very focused
on outcome-based solutions.
Instead of just listing
a bunch of services
and going at that angle,
we want you to understand
where you're going before you get there.
We do that by scaling out competencies.
We have 19 of them, a
lot of partner programs.
What we really focus on
is how do we build a relationship with AWS
to get the client there
faster and more efficiently.
So the ultimate goal of our
partnership with our clients
and with AWS is to grow the
relationships on all facets
to make agentic evolution come faster.
One thing I also really wanna discuss
is how fast AI is evolving.
We know from this conference
we are seeing frontier agents.
We're seeing different
kind of model distillation.
One thing that's interesting
is the different nuances
that we're seeing it with.
It's going everywhere from
browsing to scraping the web,
executing multi-step tasks
with strong governance.
We see it across a bunch
of different standards for security.
But when is the actual right
time to implement is key?
And that is where Atos can help you.
We know how to roadmap
and we know how to carve out the solutions
to do a consistent
strategy around agentic AI
with all the new feature
sets with them, right?
So the goal is really around
not just creating better agents,
but around better frameworks.
We want to create a deployment
and an orchestration platform with tools
and marketplaces that can build and scale
and manage the agents in real time, right?
This is not just about agility
and latency and scalability,
but this is about your individual
domain needs for that data
that's attached to the AI.
So what does this all mean?
This all means that we're
gonna start moving towards
personifying AI, right?
These agents can be self
adaptable, they can collaborate,
they can sync, and it's
all about using real-time
enterprise data that's your data.
So we're leveraging your specific data
to feed these agent workflow.
So as we start shifting more
and more towards agentic AI
we're gonna accelerate more outcomes
with that minimal human intervention.
So that's really the key, right?
So I want you to ask
yourselves the question,
is there a path for agentic AI
to artificial general intelligence, right?
What assumptions are baked into the goals
that we give AI in your own
individual organizations?
And then how do you see that growing?
So at Atos we created a
platform called Polaris AI.
The ultimate goal is to
give an extraction layer
to actually how you
build into marketplace.
As we grow and grow agentic more and more,
we're able to help you build out
those professional services.
And the objective is that
we are always client-focused
with what you need to do with your data
and your AI solutions.
So let's talk about go
to market around agentic.
You're gonna hear a lot of services
in this conference today.
You're gonna hear a lot about
what exactly is going
on, new possibilities.
But how do you get to the point
where you're actually using
this with your customers
or with your use cases specifically?
So the first one is how do we bring
the agents to our system, right?
We're seeing a lot more industry flavored
super agents, right?
As 2026 evolves, we're go to market,
there's a lot of AI targeted super agents,
we're seeing domain specific applications.
So maybe it's finance, maybe it's tax,
maybe it's accounting, whatever that is
industry standards are baked horizontally
and vertically across
all organizations now.
Autonomy, multimodal integration.
We know this, this
coming out more and more.
We're seeing different
modalities, tax vision,
whatever it is, and they're
acting with more flexibility
and they're handling those novel tasks
we don't really need to do anymore.
But last but not least,
a lot of safety alignment and oversight.
How do we put those guardrails
and frameworks around detection drifting,
ensuring alignment, and
items like run checks.
So it's tricky,
but you need to make
sure that you're prepared
and that is the next point.
How do we proactively prepare
to move towards this go to market, right?
So at Atos, one thing
that we really specify
is industry aligned solutions
where we're amplifying
the actual value of the AWS services.
So you can look at the service catalog,
you can put them together,
but how does this work
to create an outcome?
That's what we really design, right?
We design the roadmap for you.
And this is always about
business outcomes, right?
We can go and talk about
AI innovation all day,
but if you do not put that
through a business lens
you're not able to prioritize
those measurable outcomes
and connect those to things like KPIs
and actual cloud capabilities
that you're having to spend with, right?
The third, differentiation,
understanding differentiation factors
through an AI first strategy,
which you're gonna see more and more
over the next year is critical.
And that's just because
we're not just bolt on anymore, right?
We're building cloud native
now, that changes how we see AI.
So the key is to bring your vertical depth
and your AI accelerators with
that native implementation
for that faster TTV or your time to value.
And last but not least,
a really important one,
proprietary IP, the vertical AI solutions,
I wanna talk about that,
which is really critical.
How do we scale our AI
solutions vertically
and horizontally, maybe
against different geos,
different industries, different regions
is gonna be really critical
in the next year, right?
You wanna grow across all
methodologies all at once.
And then how do we look through a lens
of sovereign cloud expertise as well?
That's something that
we specialize at Atos
that we can help you with
as well as the data first architecture.
This one is very interesting, right?
We wanna make sure that we're
leveraging the data we have
in our ecosystem for our models
and for agentic AI.
It's there, we need to leverage
it and we need to make sure
that we're using it correctly.
And lat but not least,
how does this all fit
into agentic AI orchestration, right?
How does this build
and how can we help you
get there is the next step.
Thank you.
- Thanks, Justin.
So at Atos we are a large DSI.
We've got a cloud on an
infrastructure practice.
One of the things we provide
to customers is cloud advisory.
Traditionally cloud advisory has been done
with one of our cloud advisors
sitting down with customers
and talking to them about
their current environment,
their goals, and helping to
map out how they get there.
It can be quite a time consuming process
involving discussions
with multiple stakeholders
on the customer side.
And we've chosen as one of the use cases
that we've taken forward with agentic AI
to modernize that with
our Atos digital advisor.
So the idea here is that using agentic AI,
we connect to the customer's environment.
We learn a lot of information
about their environment,
connect to the web, learn
a lot about the customer
before the advisor sits down
with the key stakeholders
from the customer
for the first time.
So this frees up our advisors initially
to be able to spend more
meaningful time with customers
having more meaningful conversations.
And it's great for the customer
'cause they haven't gotta
sit down and explain
their environment to
us and spend that time,
the time can be better spent talking about
where they want to go and how
we can get there with them.
We can see on the screen here,
we've just got a couple of screenshots
of the digital advisory platform.
We look across a number of domains
and we assess the customer's
maturity in those domains.
And then that helps to have
the conversation about,
okay, what's the priority for you?
Is it security?
Is it sustainability?
That sort of thing.
And help to, you know, move
them in the right direction.
We then have agentic AI
powered reporting as well.
So it creates this maturity
assessment automatically.
It comes up with the
recommendations of how the customer
maturity can improve.
And then when the advisor
sits down with the customer,
this information's all available
to start that meaningful conversation.
As you probably expect,
given it's an AWS conference,
this is all powered by AWS services.
The front end UI that I
showed on the last screen
connects to Amazon API gateway,
which triggers a Lambda function
and then AWS step
functions kick in to answer
all of the questions
within our advisory pack.
They can be a range of technical questions
about the customer's AWS environment.
They can be a bunch of
non-technical questions
about compliance regimes
and things like that.
The step functions are triggering
Amazon Bedrock Agent Core.
So we're using the agentic AI services
that we're all hearing a lot
about this week within Bedrock,
we're storing information in Amazon S3,
we are caching information in DynamoDB.
The Amazon Bedrock Agent Core
supervisor agent kicks in.
It takes the questions
from the questionnaire
and it works out what to do with them.
If it's a question about
security and compliance,
for example, it defers it to an agent
that's doing web searching.
So for example, if this
was gonna do an assessment
for a healthcare customer here in the US
and the question was around
what compliance regimes
might that customer need to comply with
then the agent will go
out, learn from the web
that likely this customer's
gonna need to be HIPAA compliant.
If it's a question of a
more technical nature,
that gets delegated to another agent.
So for example, let's
say how does the customer
separate their networking?
That's a fairly generic question.
So the first thing that
happens is it goes to an agent
that talks via an MCP server
to the AWS documentation.
And that generic question about
how do you segregate your
networks becomes a much more
AWS specific question involving
security groups, NACLs,
AWS network firewall,
routing of transit gateways
and things like that.
That more detailed question
then gets passed on
to the next agent, which
actually does querying
via MCP of the customer's environment.
So that much more complex
question is handled
by the agent and the MCP server,
it goes off and interrogates
the customer's environment.
And then that information all
comes back into the reporting
that I talked about on the previous slide.
The human agent then sits
down with the customer,
validates that information.
So we've got human in the
loop to ensure accuracy
of the information
and they'll talk through
with the customer,
they'll discuss the relevant information,
check it for accuracy, et cetera.
And as I said before,
have a much more meaningful conversation
with customers about
how we help them to move
to where they want to be,
rather than spending all
the time talking to them
about where they currently are.
So we are over on booth 1661, we're Atos.
If you are interested in a conversation
about digital advisory or cloud
modernization and migration
or data and AI, then
please come and see us
and I wish you good day.
Have a great conference.